you
hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played in armenia's
capital yerevan in 1988 right about the
time I was just learning the rules of
the game on the white end we have the
German Grand Master Rainer nee ik his
opponent Armenian Grandmaster a shot
Anastasia this is a model game for white
against the Benoni if you are to employ
the system that white does in your own
games you certainly need to be familiar
with this central slash kingside pawn
break through middle game pawn thrust
now admittedly when we're working with a
benoni defense it seems like we're
always in some middlegame position it's
a very sharp rich opening and plenty of
games will not even reach that final
phase this is one of them so let's dive
in here and see how this game ends after
just 23 moves after these five moves if
there are two pawns one for each side
that captures my attention the most
it is d5 and c5 drawing some attention
to this gives us some insight into the
plans each side will try and undertake
note that these ponds desire to move and
at the moment they cannot so each side
will try to influence the ponds that are
preventing these pawns from moving
namely white will try to influence d6
and black will try to influence c4 let's
see how this comes about
first of all White's King sidepiece
deployment bishop on d3 night on e 2
this is keeping White's pawn structure
fluid in particular white wants to stay
out of the way of the F pawn if you go
to f3 not only are you blocking the F
pawn but you are subjecting yourself to
a pin if Bishop g4 now well white would
just punch right back and say get out of
my house and go back home
so with the night on e - what does white
ultimately want to push f4 and E 5 in 1
c5 is in what is white doing influencing
d6 so let's get some more moves in here
ISA 'kz castles captures on d5 white
takes towards the center and with this
the majorities change for each side
majority now for black on the Queen side
White has a majority on the Kings side
if you're wondering why white is giving
black this option to at some stage move
c4 well it's because white is being
consistent you don't put the night on e
2 and then end up capturing like this
the idea behind Knight to e2 is to get
in f4 and then an e5 pawn break so if
you're capturing like this you don't
have a 5 anymore
so it takes towards the center each side
wants to get their majorities rolling
now 3 2 2 4 black on the Queen side and
5 2 4 4 white on the Kings side / Center
so here we go Knight a6 multiple moves
from this point on are directed at you
getting the majorities rolling Knight a
6 is one of them looking to pivot on c7
to support b5 h3 is useful for long term
wise flight squared but more importantly
the primary function right now is to
rule out a night pivot on g4 until let's
say the e5 square
okay Knight c7 and a4 so this is
preventing black from getting the
majority rolling b5 was a threat notice
with the pressure on e4 if I don't know
white just makes a kind of a passing
move let's just say King in the corner
b5 could already be played the bishop on
d3 it's important to note is an
overloaded piece overworked piece has
two jobs so if there happens to be a
capture like this
what ends up happening is that the epon
has just been exchanged for the beep on
and this would favor team black so
that's why we have right now a for
stopping b5 continuing a six black still
has some work to do before he is in a
position to play b5 rook has to a help
and get to the b8 square Bishop g5 first
the bishop can kind of be stuck if
you're if you're playing f4 too soon mmm
the bishop it doesn't have an active
role certainly it has an active role now
being on g5 there is a pin there so
should e 5 hit it's going to hit pretty
hard
rook b8 sure enough f4 getting the
majority is wrong and from here Queen to
e8 getting out of a pin and at the same
time it is supporting this b5 advance
supporting that majority Bishop c2 is
clearing the way where 14 moves in this
is already a very critical moment big
moment for Team black right here
white's last move Bishop c2 is clearing
the way so the Queen has direct sight of
d5 white really wants this efj I've pawn
break but doing it let's say right now
well that that would be you know there's
this capture on d5 could make it capture
here but okay white wants some support
of d5 Bishop d2 Bishop to c2 gives white
that and from here we have h6 this is
the one variation I want to highlight
this is where there's a turning point in
the game after these after after this
move 14 Bishop c2 it's important for
black to just follow through here and
play b5 black has enough support for it
should play it right here and I'd like
to highlight in this variation this is
what black should be doing and we
arrived at a really difficult position
I'm about to show you a position that I
don't quite know how to assess so let me
show you
one of the the better lines here 'if
I've liked d7 in d6 this is getting
pretty crazy white is about to win the
exchange but if you do that you're going
to be giving up a strong dark square
bishop this is a really difficult
position for me to assess maybe I'll
throw this one to you who would you
rather be in this position at the moment
Black has a slight material plus but the
computer actually says it's better for
black there's a really a lot to take
into account here tough position to wrap
one's head around for me at least anyhow
this is considered best in the
computer's eyes to throw that b5 move in
there in this game we have h6 this is
giving white a wonderful window of
opportunity to seize the initiative and
start directing play here like does so
with the capture on f6 this is a capture
you really have to well you could play
it in a way quickly in this position
because there are follow-up moves that
pack a strong punch but my point here is
that you don't want to just give away
your dark square bishop for a knight
this Bishop can turn out to be an
absolute monster it's coordinated really
well with the pawns that are on dark
squares and yeah it could really turn
out to be a giant pain in white side
giant thorn however with White's follow
up this thematic central slash King side
pawn thrust I referenced at the
beginning of this video
notice how blacks Bishop is completely
shut down
'if I've is in there even though white
doesn't have enough direct support for
it this is a pawn sacrifice after a
capture white is not recapturing but
rather playing f5 this is the thematic
pawn thrust I'm referring to e5 and
after a capture
you play f5 what is accomplished exactly
with this the e5 pawn is now an obstacle
for the black pieces the bishop cannot
see the world along this main diagonal
nor can the Queen along the e-file
moreover it provides a wonderful outpost
a much more secure outpost for the white
knights knight on e5 and also let's not
forget going into john madden mode here
i realize but let's not forget that this
d5 pawn has what some mobility now this
is now past d6 in their packs a strong
punch okay after f5 what does black do
capture d6 on board - sad situation for
the knight two options choose one if you
go to the corner well you might as well
just resign 96 Knight d5 notice the
squares that are now available now that
this pawn has moved this knight on c3
has a wonderful jumping point
coordinated well with the pawn on d6
everything is being tied together very
well excellent coordination with a punch
on f6 Bishop g7 in the game rook takes
f5 and now Knight d4 we're almost at the
end of the game here Knight takes Knight
in the game and black just recaptures on
d4 here's something interesting if
Bishop takes rook white would take with
the knight and white is without question
the better side I wondered how much
better would white actually be in this
position I threw this position on the
ice plugged this position into the
computer without this rook around and
white is still the better side that's
how strong this position is for team
white doesn't even need rook and is
still the better side the serious threat
in this position is queen g4 Queen takes
bishop game over serious
okay well black doesn't take the rook
here those Knights would be killers in
the game eat aches deform and now we
have 97 check King h8 in the final move
of the game the only pop quiz I'm
throwing your way what does white play
next feel free to pause the video okay
the star move the winning move here
there are many but the absolute best is
rook f6 this is a wonderful move and I'm
sure it's one that team white was
familiar with from a game that Fischer
played against pal Benko in 1963 at the
US Championships this is preventing
blacks F pawn from advancing to f5 white
wants to now form a battering along this
diagonal and sweep in for mate so for
example okay black resigned here but if
the rook is captured this is the deadly
follow-up Queen d3 and what are you
doing about Queen h7 mate you can't run
with the king that's no help Black has
to make these kind of moves Bishop f5
you take and if d3 well at this stage
there's you don't have to focus on
getting to h7 you could take the bishop
with check and then kind of give some I
don't know long-distance mate I don't
know what you call that yeah this would
be a nice finish as well but this move
is just preventing f5 and paving the way
for a wonderful battery getting into the
h7 square no good defense for Team black
from here if let's say c4 is in stop in
Queen to d3 well the Queen has another
route into the attack and we see the
additional point behind rook f6 some
pressure against that h6 point by the
rook and Queen and soon enough there
will be some sacrifice there leading to
some mate
okay well anyhow as mentioned I feel
that this is a one of the model games
for white against the Benoni very
thematic central / King Side pawn
breakthrough you need to be familiar
with 'if I've and then after a capture
f5 anyhow as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below
hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away from it that's all for
now take care bye
you